let's say you want to find out sine of 7
PI over 12 now this isn't one that we
memorized on the unit circle so what we
can do is we can take two angles that
either add or subtract to give us 7 PI
over 12 using those two angles that we
know on the unit circle so sometimes
students they struggle a little bit with
radians so what you might want to do is
change 7 PI over 12 into degrees so
let's do that here 7 PI over 12
multiplied by 180 over PI the PI radians
cancel 12 wheels into 180 15 times 7
times 15 is 105 degrees so now we just
have to ask ourselves what two angles
that we know on the unit circle add up
to 105 so that would be like 60 and 45
so what we're going to do is we're going
to write this as sine of 60 plus 45 so
you can see in our formula here is 60
and B is 45 I'm going to substitute
those in for a and B on the right side
of the equation so this equals sine of
60 cosine 45 plus cosine 60 times the
sine of 45 okay now you want to
reference your unit circle if you want
to review that you can go to my video on
unit circle but here sine of 60 equals
square root 3/2 cosine 45 is square root
2 over 2 cosine 60 is 1/2 and sine of 45
is square root 2 over 2 multiply these
together square root 6 over 4 plus
square root 2 over 4 so I'm just
multiplying numerators and denominators
and then because these have the same
denominator we can combine them together
into one fraction so square root of 6
plus square root of 2 all divided by 4
so this is an exact answer you can of
course go to your calculator and find
out what sine of 105 degrees is that's
going to give you a long decimal this is
exact answer so sometimes it's helpful
to have the exact value for sine of 105
degrees and that's how you would do it
so now let's look at another example
here what they're giving us is what you
can see is actually the right side of
this equation and you want to try to
identify which one it is that they're
giving us it looks like it's cosine
cosine minus sine sine cosine cosine
minus sine sine you can see that's going
to be the cosine sum formula okay
because these are the opposite right for
cosine so here what we have is cosine of
35 plus 85 35 plus 85 is 120 degrees so
this is cosine of 120 and we know from
our unit circle cosine of 120 equals
let's see negative one half okay so
that's how we work with the formula in
Reverse so they're giving us the right
side and we're condensing it to the left
side in this first problem they gave us
the left side and we expanded to solve
using the right side of the identity so
now the last question we're going to
talk about is how do you find the
tangent of U minus V if sine of U equals
512 and cosine of V equals 3/5 both
angle U and V are in Quadrant three okay
so what I recommend for this one is to
draw the two triangles in their
respective third quadrant so we'll do
that here and so here we've got angle u
in the third quadrant
okay so here's you here's V okay I don't
know why they use U and V those
sometimes are difficult because they
look similar but this is U and this is V
sine of U equals the opposite over the
hypotenuse notice the hypotenuse is
always positive the radius is always
positive and if you do the Pythagorean
theorem
I'm gonna change this problem here a
little bit to make this a little bit
easier let's call this 5 thirteenth's
and we'll make this negative 12 okay so
you're just solving for the missing side
of a triangle and notice that you're
going to the left that's why this
segment here is negative and here you're
going down that's negative but the
radius for the hypotenuse is always
positive okay for this one cosine of
angle V we have 3/5 so cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse okay
so if we solve for the missing side this
is going to be negative 4 just using
Pythagorean theorem okay so there we go
so there's our two triangles I had to
adjust these a little bit to make the
numbers you know work out a little bit
easier for our example okay so now what
we're going to do is we're going to find
out what is the tangent of U minus V so
here you can see we're using this
tangent difference formula tangent of U
minus V and so what we're going to do is
we're going to expand this out look over
here we've got tangent of U minus
tangent of V all divided by one plus
tangent of U times the tangent of V okay
so where do we find the tangent of U we
go to the triangle tangent is opposite
over adjacent so that's going to be five
twelfths minus the tangent of V which is
opposite over adjacent so that's going
to be 4/3 divided by one plus the
tangent of U which is what we got over
here 512 times the tangent of U which is
what we saw for here which is 4/3 notice
that the negatives cancel so that's why
we have these are positive values now
all you have to do is just do some
arithmetic and simplify this complex
fraction get common denominators get
common denominators and then dividing is
like multiplying by the reciprocal and
you can simplify this down so this is
how to find tangent of U minus V when
they give you two angles just draw those
in the quadrant okay that they're saying
that they're in and solve for the
missing side that's the key and then pay
attention if you're going left it's
negative
right is positive up is positive and
down is negative and so this these are
some examples for how do you work with
the sum and difference formulas you know
with trigonometric functions and it's a
way of getting no exact values okay when
you don't necessarily know those values
on the unit circle the ones we study the
multiples of 30 45 60 90 like that okay
so I'll see you in the next video